spending hours in queues has become the
norm across sri lanka
starting with food rice sugar and milk
powder now it's cooking gas and diesel
that are in short supply
i haven't eaten from the morning and i
can't even go drink some water i would
lose my place otherwise
after spending so many hours in queues
we can only run about two and a half
days we can't keep doing this so we
appeal for this problem to be solved
the shortages are a result of the
government not having enough dollars to
pay for imports this is because its
foreign earnings and reserves have been
rapidly declining since 2019.
huge debt repayments have eaten into a
big chunk of available resources
the crisis has affected all sectors
including public transport
operators say they are struggling to
survive from day to day
on the one hand there's no electricity
they cut power for seven and a half
hours the diesel stocks that come half
is given for power generation it's only
half the stock that's used for
everything else after months of coping
people are protesting here in chile
north of colombo fishermen complain they
don't have fuel for their boats
my husband can't go to sea there's no
diesel i hope those responsible are
struck by lightning
in colombo a silent protest
enough is enough says one banner
stop ruining my country reads another
months of skyrocketing prices and
shortages of food medicine cooking gas
and fuel have made sri lankans
frustrated and angry
to make matters worse
they've suffered through the worst power
cuts to be imposed in more than 25 years
seven and a half hour interruptions a
day are causing chaos among all segments
of the population
sri lanka's public utilities regulator
says it has been pushing to solve the
power crisis this has become a national
issue so
necessary
the attention has not been paid by the
political hierarchy then and now and the
other authorities so we have been
fighting you know
with almost everyone to sort out this
issue increasing prices and shortages
are not unique to sri lanka but people
here say their leaders have aggravated
the situation through years of
corruption and mismanagement
fernandez al jazeera colombo